I took a KVMO fit 22 plus got permeability test
about four months ago.
One thing it showed me was a sensitivity to coffee.
So I switched from coffee enemas to yearma mate enemas.
I would like to retest.
Does it make sense to retest now?
Well, I'm not doing coffee enemas
and see if the coffee protein shows up at the test.
Or would it be more productive to start the coffee enemas
back up again and do the test after the coffee enemas
again for about a month and see if the coffee proteins
show up again in the test.
Well, this is long been the discussion
of functional practitioners.
Whether you should, okay, let's say same example would be
I think a sensitive to gluten.
So I went gluten free.
I've been gluten free for three months.
And then I did a blood test to find out
if I have gluten sensitivity.
Was that why is there should I go back on gluten
to see if I have more gluten peptide circulated in my body?
Am I going to pick up a greater sensitivity?
The way I've always answered that is,
okay, how are you living your life?
Are you not eating that food on a regular basis anyhow?
And you plan to stay gluten free?
Yes, I plan to stay gluten free.
How I feel better gluten free.
Okay, well then do the test again be gluten free.
Or no, I want to go back on gluten.
Well, then it might be good to eat a little gluten
and because I haven't felt any different
being off of gluten will eat some gluten
and then do the test again.
If it comes back positive, gluten isn't a good example
because if you have, if you show gliated peptides,
you're probably never going to be able to go back on gluten.
So that's not wasn't a good example in my question,
but in this case, I would say it might be better
to go back on the coffee enemas, do that for a month
and then retest to see if it comes back positive
because you do want to be on the coffee enemas.
So I think that would be a better test.
So the question is really,
should I put my body under that environmental stress
when I do the test?
Or should I try to stay off of it and do the test?
The argument is if you stay off of it and do the test,
it might show negative now so you think you're okay
and then as soon as you go back on it again,
your body flares up in immune response
and you start making IGG and IGA antibodies
against that thing with this case coffee
and you're back in the square and what again
you're causing inflammation.
So I think it's better to put your body under stress
in a case like this, whatever you want to go back to
then put it back under that stress
and see if it comes up positive.
I didn't even finish the question.
I'm asking a relation to my breast lump
which is very close to the surface.
While a while ago I asked if it would be smart
to do a contrast therapy heat or cold over the lump
to stress it and you said yes to try that.
I got to think and know that the contrast therapy
also increases blood flow to the area
and I thought that was something that we're trying
not to do with tumor so can you explain
the seemingly conflict of this?
Well, if you're finished with cold,
I should have been more specific
than you're not necessarily increasing blood flow.
For instance, it's very common with somebody
with muscular skeletal injury,
let's say you sprayed your ankle.
They say, what do they say?
You know, rest, which is to elevate and to put cool on it
and to put always iced it and things like that.
What's the acronym it's called?
Rice, it's rest, ice, I don't forget.
But to help with the sprayed ankle.
But the truth is, you know, if you've worked with people
with muscular skeletal injuries like I have years ago,
many times people react negatively to cold
and they work more positively to heat or vice versa.
Everybody's different.
So what are the ways that you can help with that
is to alternate hot and cold.
Just like do a minute of cold, a minute of heat,
a minute of cold, a minute of heat
and then finish with cold.
And see if that pumping action actually helps with the healing.
So that can be something to try.
And with doing anything like over a tumor or something,
you want to be very careful and be extra-visual to see
if you felt like that did not feel good.
I would say make it worse right away.
It wasn't helping and then you would scratch that.
But everybody's a little bit different.
And it's worth a try to see if something helps.